all right well I guess we'll get started
so thank you guys all for coming I know
you guys all have a lot of questions I'm
sure so we'll get into that in a little
bit I just kind of wanted to give you
guys a little background on me and kind
of what's made me make movies and do
what I do
part of my filmmaking process started
when I was very young before even you
know making my first feature which I did
at 18 years old you know I would I would
get a sign like a book report for school
in like middle school and I would make a
short film about why I didn't want to do
a book report and I remember my my
parents got called in to my biology
class to say like hey why why is he not
you know doing well on any of these
tests when he's you know why is he not
studying why's he not this and I
remember telling my parents well I don't
need biology when I become a filmmaker
and and you know to this day I really
haven't had to use biology other than
stuff you can google but just saying so
anyways that also kind of goes with my
course curriculum for what we're going
to talk about here cuz I think it's
important to gear towards people strong
suits and teach them what they want to
learn and and you know geared towards
that because not anybody can be put in a
box everybody's unique and different so
we're gonna talk about that and we're
gonna talk about what's worked for me
and you guys can you know do that or do
something different I want to say like
by no means am i a master this is not a
master class I am learning still you
know but I can tell you what's worked
for me so far and and kind of just go
from there so at 18 years old I made my
first feature for seven thousand dollars
because I was I decided okay well Robert
Rodriguez only needs his you know only
needed seven thousand dollars for his
first movie that's all I need so I made
it
and I did every job imaginable I you
know I I ran the boom while you know
figuring out crafty while producing
while writing it while directing it I
did it I did the sound design I did
absolutely everything and the movie was
awful it was completely terrible and it
was my first feature it came out but I
was very fortunate that people gave me
good reviews because they didn't want to
like talk [ __ ] on a who am I allowed to
curse okay they didn't want to talk crap
on a on an eighteen-year-old filmmakers
first movie so I got I got good reviews
but what I did learn is what didn't work
because one thing I've learned about
filmmaking for me is I grow every time I
make a movie it's like a muscle so you
have to train it and flex it so part of
what I've also learned is I'm sure all
of you guys have watched movies when you
watch a movie it's easy to look at it
and go oh well I would have done that or
I would have changed this well look at
that for your own movies because for my
movies I've learned what I would do
differently by watching it and going off
should have done that oh man and
perspective really helps you grow so
when you make your first movie be it a
short film or a feature film do the best
you can but it doesn't have to be
perfect
you can grow from there you know part of
what I think is any time I do a movie I
tried new things I like to experiment I
like to do things I wouldn't normally do
like the last feature I just shot I was
really excited about the last one I
directed because the entire movie was
almost one person trapped against the
elements in one location so it was
impossible for me to fall into standard
coverage I couldn't fall into you know
wide shot over the shoulder over the
shoulder close up close up because
there's only one person so I had to find
interesting and fragmented ways to cover
this person in coverage for the movie
that I wouldn't have done on any other
movie so I think it's important to
challenge yourself and put yourself out
of out of what you would be comfortable
in it's why I'm doing this action movie
next because you want to be able to
figure out how to do something
differently
than what you would normally do the
other thing is preparedness now I as a
filmmaker make everything in prep and
and it's not it was not always like that
so I wish I had this cheat code in the
beginning because literally it is a
cheat code everybody says prep but like
when I say prep really do prep plan your
movie plan your best-case scenario
worst-case scenario everything shot
listed and you'd be surprised I've made
tons and tons of movies as a producer
and not everybody shot lists I've been
on tons and tons of sets and not
everybody shot lists shot list your
movie now in mind you the shot list is
gonna end up being a wish list but it'll
help you think quickly because while you
have to think on your toes you can
decide between hey am I gonna cut one of
these shots or am I going to you know
stay in this coverage or am I going to
have to do something completely
different because the location looks
different shot list your movie and plan
it out it's important because it helps
you pre-visualize how you're going to
shoot the scene and also when you
pre-visualize it you're writing out the
shots and when you're writing out the
shots you are able to communicate that
to your DP which helps you be able to
figure out stuff with your actors more
onset you don't have to be talking to
the DP and I'll tell you being able to
focus on your actors is is key because
on a lot of these movies you will not
have a ton of time so being able to
really work the scenes with your actors
give them direction very very important
and I know it seems basic but believe me
when you're in the thick of it and there
is crazy stuff going on it's not basic
at all because you'll be called and
you'll say hey you know this was
supposed to be a night exterior well we
don't have permits to shoot at night so
we have to do this and Oh a perfect
example for me is when I was filming my
movie pernicious we were shooting it in
Thailand okay I had a whole plan about
how they were gonna drive up it was in
the in the script they're driving up to
the house in a in a cab and I get a call
the night before filming during monsoon
season the entire exterior of the house
was so flooded that you would have to
wade through water up to your waist to
get to the house so
I figured okay well we'll push it a day
we'll build like a little pier and we'll
have them come up on a boat and we
literally got like a little speedboat
and put it on the water and it was deep
enough that you could actually put a
speedboat on it and it had great
production value it looked good
but being able to figure out these
things you know on the fly is only
because you're not thinking of
everything else that you have to plan
plan it ahead and it helps you think
better in the moment that's that's
definitely the best advice I can give
anybody for sure going back to when I
was talking about when you look at your
movies and you can you can figure out
what you would have done differently I
think and I personally believe how many
of you guys
by a show of hands how many of you have
camera phones how many of you have made
short films before okay how many of you
have made you know a bunch of short
films if you haven't and you have a
camera phone in your pocket and you want
to be a filmmaker there's absolutely no
excuse for you to not be testing stuff
out and trying stuff on the weekends
writing a little script working with
friends building it hey even you could
do a feature might one of my features
one of my first features was a five
hundred dollar budget movie that was
shot entirely on an iPhone and it was
the first movie to be shot on an iPhone
even though I don't get credit for that
for some reason I don't I don't know
what happened there but apparently
somebody else did it like two weeks
later and they got the credit it doesn't
matter either way what I'm trying to say
is what we realized when we were making
that movie is we geared it towards the
limited resources we had we had to tell
a story that was just about characters
just about what we can access and what
we could do and what we had all the
money went to just food that's it so
everything else was you know just things
that we had people we knew everybody
donated their time but if you start
writing towards that ideology and
started crafting towards that then when
you know okay I can get this much money
to make a movie well I'll do that and
you start building and I think it's
important and for me it's worked to
build every time I make a movie I make
a little bit bigger and a little bit
better every time and I've grown from
like you know these five hundred dollar
budgets seven hundred thousand dollar
budgets to you know upwards of a million
dollars so I think it's important to to
do these things and and and really flex
the muscle of making movies
some of you seem like you have some
questions so I'm gonna jump in answer
some questions and then I'll go back to
like monologuing but you know who wants
to ask a question first you look at her
start do you like you know any ones you
like oh they're like yeah so I did I did
I did location scouts but it's you know
in a perfect world you'll be able to see
your locations first but if not you know
you kind of just guesstimate your
location and and go from there part of
what I do if somebody could give me a
piece of paper and a pen and I can kind
of show you how I how I first now I can
like visualize this in my head but how I
first started doing shot list is we'll
grab this yeah Oh clip or you write yeah
I'll say like you know okay I want to do
like a wide a medium will do a tracking
shot but also like let's say you know we
have a room a square room right can
everybody see this or we'll just pass it
around so if we have a square room and
there's two people in it right so this
is a person this is a person that's the
way they're looking that's the way
they're looking cuz their nose is that
way right it's a little crude drawing
but I figure okay so my camera's gonna
go here next set up I'll be here maybe I
want to do a tracking shot over here and
we'll track from here to here maybe I
want this person to walk this way
so I'll go from here they'll confront
them so I want to get a tighter here and
a tighter there right so now I've
planned out all this stuff kind of just
figuring out just guesstimating stuff
and it also helps you pre-visualize
things so you're just kind of figuring
this out and then you say okay so what
am i doing I'm doing you know a tracking
a wide master and then
you know we could do an
over-the-shoulder tracking them forward
we'll do that handheld and then I want
to be in the center so we're gonna go
you know I'd say down the barrel
straight you know it's an awkward scene
maybe so we're gonna do like wide-angle
but you start doing and figuring out
where you're putting your camera and
where it is within the space your
guesstimating that and not only that
like this will help your DP figure out
where to light from not only that it'll
figure out where you want to tell your
actors like hey you're gonna walk in
you're gonna do this this is how you're
moving so you're already kind of
prefiguring out you're blocking while
you're doing this then you go to your
shot list but it's kind of like a little
like overhead blocking map of figuring
out what you're going to do so I think
from there you can figure out your shots
usually and I think it helps for me at
least it's and I try to do it for every
scene but I think you know really
depends it really depends because like
you want to do your wide first but
sometimes you'll be in a case where like
you have an actor who's like a big name
who can only be there like you know for
a certain amount of time and like maybe
you wanted like fire off all their
coverage first and then like you know in
the you realize that in the master if
you have them turns the opposite
direction you could just use a bot body
double so you're like behind them so you
just get somebody who looks like them so
you have to figure out how to plan it
you know so so sometimes you have to be
creative so knowing these things helps
like for instance when I was shooting
blood lake which was a horror movie I
did for Animal Planet
we had Christopher Lloyd for only two
days so 90% of the scenes that
Christopher Lloyd was in other than like
you know like I think two of them I shot
up only his coverage for like a couple
days then I had to go back and shoot
everybody else's stuff so like I I think
like you know it depends on you know
what you have to look at is what are the
variables what are you dealing with and
what's what what are your problems gonna
be and then you troubleshoot in
pre-production you troubleshoot for
everything prior and then that's how you
can figure out okay well I can't do my
master first because he can only be here
for X amount of time
so I have to find a way to block it so
his back is to me because it'll be easy
to figure out how to match you know how
he looks now mind you you know it you
will always be in that scenario but
being prepared for something like that
because also when you're dealing with a
lower budget movie getting a bigger name
actor if you can get them they're
usually going to want to be there for
less days so finding a way to condense
them to like you know two three four
days is really gonna help you so I mean
that's you know cuz if you say hey I
want you for you know eighteen days a
lot of the time they need a lot more
money but if you're able to get them for
only you know a couple days and shoot
them out they'll they're willing to go
well it's only like a couple days of my
time like let's try it so I think that's
also something to be prepared for and
figure out if there's big rolls you know
in there that can be condensed that are
like you know throughout the movie but
they're you know in certain areas and
only like in a couple locations that's a
good place to put a bigger name for sure
but they say something like hey you
gotta like I'm Bethany wasn't my like
Mary Shannon daughter yes yes so the
deal like the anything like how much
she's gonna get paid yeah I negotiated
that but I mean that that for me that
was easier with Shannon for Bethany
because I daughter to already worked
with her a few times so like you know I
was able to talk with her and her reps
and they already knew me because I think
we work together like three times before
that or something and mind you I wrote
that role specifically for her and I
told her while I was writing it I was
like hey I'm writing a role specifically
for you so you better do it and then I
just guilt-tripped her for like you know
a really long time so that like by the
time she got it I was like hey isn't
this wonderful it's written just for you
and she's like yeah yeah this is great
but she was going to do it either way so
but that's the thing is you know I think
also actors respond to passion so if
you're able to find a way to get in
person with them you know if you can
find like talk to the reps but like say
hey like
making an offer but I'd love to get on a
phone call with them or I'd love to like
meet them or something if you can get
that to happen they're more likely to
say yes because it's harder for people
to say no to somebody that they've seen
and met versus like just a random you
know name and an email so I love those
type of stories and obviously you know
the level where do you think the line
between producer and director gets drawn
is awesome yeah so I mean for me as a as
a as a director I pretty much produced
almost every movie I've directed you
know there's a couple that I didn't and
I totally regret that because also I
feel like you know certain times you
have the money is not being spent in the
right places because you don't know
where it's being spent as a director and
you'll just be like hey I need this
thing and they'll be like well I don't
know if you could have it and it's like
you know as a director while you're
producing I think it's important on a
level to do that so you can be like okay
do I want you know an extra day of
shooting or do I want this you know this
really cool lens package you know what
what what matters more to me and I think
you know it's important to be able to
make those decisions on an indie level
listen on a bigger level where you can
afford everything
I mean I'd imagine that you know it
wouldn't matter but on an indie level
you want to be able to be involved and I
mean as a producer I've produced a lot
of movies what started happening for me
is I I directed a lot of movies and I
had a bunch of directors start
contacting me saying hey you know howhow
are you getting like this for on the
budgets you have because they had bigger
budgets than me but they weren't getting
the same kind of like locations or you
know actors or whatever it was and so I
was like oh well you know I do this this
and this and they're like hey well can
you do that on my movies for me I was
like yeah sure so they would just hire
me to work on their films so I would say
producing is probably directing without
the fun stuff it's not for me at least
it's like hey you get a you get acquire
all the things do all the pre-production
stuff and
on set you got to be really bored and
just put out fires and it's it's way
less thing baby
well afterwards afterwards yeah but I
mean it's it's also a way it's not as
you know directing is is more of a like
oh you know it's more of an artistic
thing and people are are you'd get more
accolades for that I don't think you
know as much with producing but on the
flip side of you know producing I mind
you I I really enjoy it but I do i do
producing a very different way and I
think a lot of people do because I try
to intentionally not get involved with
the creative because if I start turning
on that side of my brain I will start to
try and direct and so I don't want to do
that so as a producer I stay away from
the monitor because I don't want to be
sitting there and going hey why aren't
you getting this shot like hey well
let's do this out of the reverse when
you're directing and not producing yeah
I mean do you have to shut off that
producer so your brain and just sort of
say okay I'm gonna live in this world
producer James and director James get
into a lot of fights I'll tell you that
much III get into a lot of fights with
myself where I'm like ah you know like I
really need this but they're like and
then I'm like but I can't afford it I
feel like when when I'm directing and
producing there there are moments where
like I feel kind of like Gollum from
Lord of the Rings like where I'm just
like you know or my process no no that's
good and I'm like going back and forth
like it's really and I could do that
better if I really try hold on small so
yeah I could do the voice but uh but
like I so I go back and forth with these
boring things in my mind and I think
that it's important to have those fights
in your mind and internally because if
you keep pushing for something mentally
it means that you really think you need
it and you know I've learned that if you
really think you need it you need it so
so fight for the things you believe in
and and I think a lot of people make the
mistake of going for whatever's cheapest
and easiest versus what would be best
for the movie and and what you need to
realize is the movies forever so always
do what you honestly feel is best for
the movie unless you're putting somebody
in danger
never put somebody in danger but
other than that do what you feel is best
for the movie are you so financing you
get financing you free salesmen so I saw
a lot of different things so I've gotten
into like the pre-sale thing so doing a
lot of pre-sales is it's kind of the way
the markets been going a lot of people
do pre-sales so part of that is being
able to show that you've done a movie
before so I do recommend if you can do
something go out and do it but I
experience like I'm one of my movies
it got shopped out to all these
distributors and then I found out like a
bunch of distributors made offers on the
movie and you know they got turned down
by my producers and so I went to those
you know distributors and like hey would
you like to buy this movie like if I
made something in the same genre and a
lot of the time they were like yeah
because what we're in is there's a lot
of people hungry for content and anybody
who tells you that like the the film
industry is taking like a dip and blah
blah blah
that's distributors trying to lowball
you and convince you that people aren't
making money and doing stuff there I
mean the low low low budget movies
aren't making the kind of money that
they did a long time ago but you're
seeing a lot of distributors spend more
money on bigger movies so it's a lot of
the time is it's you know it's a buyers
market and a seller's market so you have
distributors that are going to try and
take advantage of you and lie to you and
tell you hey this is how it is this is
how it always is and then you'll you'll
go through like a you know a loop of all
these people saying this but you just
have to break through that and get above
that because a lot of those people are
just gonna try and convince you that you
can't you know oh nobody spends money on
I'm telling you they spend money on
movies I wouldn't be making them if they
didn't so so don't let them lie to you
about that for sure probably it's a
super free did you get to a point where
you went from my best seven thousand
bucks
seven thousand dollar budget to like Oh
Welman amount or was it just more green
haha I mean for me it was it was really
interesting because you know when I said
I did every job on my first film I
really did like every job so then all of
a sudden like people would be like
moving lights and I'm like oh we have a
person for that people do these things
and so I think I came from why I
appreciate my crew so much on my movies
is I come from you know I feel like
they've just taken away like all this
different responsibilities that I had to
do and I've been able to focus just on
the creative more so so I think it's
really important to rely on your crew
treat them well and also think about
this there are so many brilliant people
on set around you at all times and film
is a living breathing thing it's a
collaborative medium so you have to
remember that you know if you are around
all these people if they have an idea
it's okay if you're directing a movie
it's okay if they have a great idea and
you think it works towards your movie
run with it as a director you don't
always have to be the person who has the
best ideas but you have to be able to
recognize good ideas and if they fit
towards your towards your overall vision
so I think that's important give people
some creative freedom work with them
it's why you know you you don't have to
micromanage everything you know but and
I think people who are once you get
secured in your position you won't be
afraid to allow people to say hey you
know what about this like if you're
talking with your DP and you're saying
hey this is what I was shot listing this
is what you think like I shot lists with
my DP now I sit down and do the whole
thing with the DP because I'm like
alright these are the shots I'm thinking
and he's like well what about if we add
this and do this and it's great we you
come up with collaboration you do
different things and you you talk about
all this stuff and you have these
comments the best thing is to do with
your department heads though is to have
these conversations in prep so you're
not having to like quickly make those
decisions on set but you're going okay
well I was thinking like this is what
we're gonna do with this lighting scheme
what do you think okay great well you
know I was thinking we were gonna like
have like a bluish hue wait no we think
green would work better have these
conversations and go back and forth and
you once you start to think about it and
visualize it it's okay to to
take recommendations from other people
and I think it's important to allow
yourself to and I stress this a lot
because I have watched a lot of people
on many times I've visited sets watch
behind the scenes people are really
insecure about their position and will
not allow anybody to chime in at all and
I understand on set it's hard because
the problem is is if you let one person
chime in the peanut gallery goes and
then everybody just has a discussion and
you lose time so I suggest have these
conversations in advance and so you're
able to hey good how are you I remember
you yeah sorry didn't mean to segue so
how much in post then do you let
everybody like your supervisor
so sometimes depending on the budget you
know if not I'm the post supervisor and
so do you do you let your GP then deal
with coloring so I have my DP sit with
me during color okay I you know I'll do
it but I I well let me rephrase that I
invite my DP to color and try to set a
time for them to also be there but
sometimes they can't always make it but
I always invite them to color and you
know as you know when I'm on set I'll
have a script D marked down my favorite
takes and I have my editor work off of
my favorite takes and I'll say a pieces
of this one pieces of that one whatever
to the script II and then I have them do
you know a rough cut and then from there
I'll sit with them and and and work the
cut from there but I let them kind of do
their thing first and so who do you take
most you advice on something if somebody
comes in and says hey that may be fun
here man I mean are you who you open to
most okay I mean it really depends on
you know what the movie is and and you
know what the collaborative experience
was you know so for me you know I've had
I've had you know my DP saying hey you
know maybe we should do another and I'm
like yeah let's just do it you know or
I'll have you know my script II say hey
you know what do you think we should do
them another
should we move on and I'll go what do
you think and it'll be like oh well you
know we should do another I'm like great
let's do it you know but also in the
Edit I like to you know arrange stuff
and I'll show it to you know my
producers sometimes my other producers
have them chime in
usually like I'll lock my director's cut
and then open it up to you know my
producers sometimes I'll take my movie
after I've locked you know my director's
cut and I'll invite a whole bunch of
friends that have no idea anything about
the movie and usually people that have
nothing to do with film at all and I'll
show them the movie and I'll ask them a
bunch of questions that I've prepared
and say hey what did you think of this
did this work for you blah blah blah and
like you know I'll also watch them and
see okay at what point do they start
checking their phones remote did one of
them just check the phone or multiple
ones is there like a point where it lags
and I start to look at that as far as
comedy goes again I'm not funny
so like I don't know you know I've done
I've done a comedy pilot that was ended
up being pretty dark so I mean you know
comedy I definitely tend to defer to the
writer I you know I work with the actors
but a lot of comedy is about timing so
you know finding a way to have actors
you know play off of each other a but a
lot of a lot of that is you want to
defer to the writer will you change your
drivers cut based on some of the notes
that you get yeah unless I think they're
completely horrendous yeah I mean you
know I've had I've had notes that are
just crazy before where you know I've
had people say hey why don't we just put
this scene in the beginning of the movie
and I'm like but that's where our lead
character you know gets killed and that
was the twist ending and they're like
yeah but it's we meet we need it to be
like faster paced in the beginning so
let's just kill this person right here
I'm like well I try to like think about
it and I go let me think about that and
then I come back and I'll decide later
but like you know sometimes you get
really crazy notes where you're just
like I don't know if I can handle them
so sometimes you have to come up with
creative ways also sometimes especially
if you're working for someone to address
their note with
but still keep your creative vision
intact
so that's let's you know I try to do
that a lot but the other thing is like
look if I get like an outlandish note
and then I show it to a couple other
people and they give me the same note
well then it's not outlandish so you
know you you you you kind of try to
weigh two things but I mean I've
experienced some some really weird notes
and you'll mostly experience the
weirdest notes in the writing phase
you'll have like really really weird
notes where you'll have like people ask
a question like oh well you know he
walked into this bar but can it be like
you know can me walk over here - is that
possible and it's like yeah of course
that's easy to do I've gotten very weird
writing notes you know
yeah like did you show them the script
like or you shot the movie they just
never just gave him the movie you don't
think like you know if he solid did you
show them the script or did you like the
movie so I told them I was gonna make a
horror movie that was going to be like
supernatural and I they asked me like
what it would be about and so I wrote
out like a treatment and they're like
okay cool
and then from there I made the script
and then she went into production well
they put up an mg and what you do with
that is it's like a minimum guarantee
it's them like you bank that paper so
they give you like a contract that says
they're gonna spend X amount of dollars
on this movie when it's done and
completed and you take that mg Bank it
so you'll go to like either a private
investor depending on how big the mg is
you either go to private equity or you
go to you know one of these finance
companies that will finance it for a fee
so they'll take like you know let's say
using round numbers let's say it's like
$100,000 mg they'll give you like
$85,000 for that so that and then they
take over the contract so they become
the name on the contract so they get
paid out as soon as the movies too
and then you have a certain amount of
time that you have to deliver it for the
mg to be fulfilled so then you leave it
correct unless you unless you sell
foreign and and raised you know or
unless you raise equity against what
foreign would do you know it depends it
really depends it depends on what you're
gonna do and you know what you believe
so either if you know sell the foreign
and the domestic and you know use those
to make the movie or what you do is you
raise a little bit of money then sell
domestic and then you know make it for
that and so you kind of play both of
them together there's different
combinations depending on what kind of
movie you're making and what your budget
range is as I guess going for or how do
you even get the get in to say hey I'm
making this movie how good meetings are
networking getting in there getting I
mean a lot of that is being able to show
that you've done stuff so it's one of
these chicken and egg thing so I think
that's why I keep saying like try and do
something or or get somebody involved
that's done stuff but try and do
something that's kind of you know geared
towards what you can afford and then go
from there
because if you can show them something
and say hey this is what we've done this
is what it looks like I can do something
similar to this but and we're looking at
getting like this talent this talent in
this talent and try and get them to
agree to you know like 30 different cast
names and you know you'll be like I'll
get like two of these people and so that
way like you have 30 people to work off
of you know or like 40 people to like
try and get to fulfill what they want I
have worked with casting directors
before I like casting directors but as
as a producer a lot of the times I have
to be my own casting director because
you're going after the cast that
fulfills you know what the distributor
wants and so you have to do that and
lock that in first and a lot of the time
you know when you're doing that you have
to give these roles to them so you end
up with not a lot of roles left and so
you know I tell a lot of people like you
know you'd love to cast all these
different people in the movie but by the
end of the day after you've cast like
you know you know four or five names you
know all you have is day players left so
you're like okay you know am i you know
am I going to pay a casting director to
do that or am I going to go through you
know contacts that I've made and have
people that I know just play these roles
instead that I know can accomplish it
pour time een I am I'm different than a
lot of people and in this sense that
like you know I I watch people's movies
and decide off of performances that I've
seen can they pull off something in my
movie or not versus like I don't think
somebody coming into a room is going to
tell me whether or not they can act
because somebody can either spend a lot
of time preparing for one single scene
and do a really good job with that but
do a horrible job on set or somebody
could not have time to prepare vomit in
the room and do an amazing job on set
and I've experienced both so I tend to
just try and watch what they've done in
films and go from there green and cold
cut their way to Talent
in terms of access yeah that would make
sense I mean it would make sense for
sure in terms of access for sure I think
you know it let's say you don't have any
relationships at an agency I would
personally try at first to you know call
into an agency because if you're
financed and you're actually making the
movie and the script is good you know
nobody's going to turn you away they'll
ask for a proof of financing but
nobody's going to turn you away if you
actually have a movie you know they'll
at least hear you out and you know
remind you that doesn't mean that you're
gonna get you know you're not gonna come
in and get like you know I don't know
like Nicole Kidman or something like
that but you will have access to people
on their roster someone at least and
they're gonna try and pitch you people
depending on you know your budget range
and stuff like that that'll happen
regardless I think
if you're able to prove that your
finance and they like the script I have
not talked about writing yet a little
bit actually just notes but you talked
about the process of processing people
see what you're doing when the scripts
come in are they in a bubble if they're
I mean it really depends cuz you know it
depends on the situation because for me
I've had times where I've been hired to
write a script and you know sometimes
one of the times and I'm not gonna say
when but I was hired to write a feature
script and they're like hey can you turn
it in on Monday and I'm like it's it's
Friday and they're like oh yeah that's
good so and I'm like I can't do that and
they're like okay okay I'm like I need
way more time they're like okay so
Tuesday that there's like okay so you
know it's so you know if you're in a if
you're like that you you literally are
in a vacuum I don't suggest doing that
but for me what works writing I I think
the biggest thing when I talk to any
writer is they are afraid of the blank
page so for me I just word vomit onto
the page I just put a whole bunch of
stuff on the page I don't think about it
I just throw it on there and then it's
easy to rewrite from there because you
go oh well this doesn't make sense
oh it's like so you start changing stuff
and you start trying to give you know
people different voices and different
you know make them sound unique and
start to shape it from there but I think
just kind of vomiting it onto the page
is important I also I'll come up with
you know a beat sheet before that and
kind of like come up with all the beats
throughout the whole movie so I'm like
okay you know seeing where this happens
scene where he goes to hear scene where
this happens scene where they have a
conversation about this so like kind of
break it out like that then do like a
treatment and then go to script but once
I met script I just like the word vomit
onto the page and
clean it up from there and then once I
get the script to a place where I'm not
completely terrified about it I will
show it to you know a couple friends
that I trust that write scripts and have
them kind of give me notes and on the
flip side you know I offer that same to
them because that's the only reason why
they would do it for me so mind you like
if you have people you trust do the same
for them that you you would ask them to
do for you I also found that you know I
don't like to work in a vacuum at all I
need to be able to bounce ideas off of
people because I sometimes hearing aid
and seeing how they react and then going
from there really helps me figure stuff
out so I actually like to work with a
writing partner I used to write my
scripts by myself but I like to work
with a writing partner because I think
talking it out and going through this
and going hey well this and what about
that and and just having that like
conversation helps me flesh it out more
than just like you know going oh what am
I gonna do here Oh cuz like a lot of
people experience writer's block but I
think if you have somebody who can push
you back and forth I think that really
helps also setting up deadlines is
really important even if you don't have
one creating some like deadline or
finding a situation where a deadline can
be created will help you actually finish
the script you have like a lot of like
little but then I'll go back to all the
women and all the work on this one try
to know do you do that like when you
write like a bunch of like stories are
you gonna just book on one I I try to
focus on one I mean the the problem I
have is a lot of the scripts that I I do
end up you know like I I'm making them
towards like being made at the time so I
try not to jump around but I would say
that you know jumping around maybe might
work if you're I I did that a lot
earlier on I think just so because any
time I would get writer's block I would
just jump from one to the other and then
come back to it but I will say that I
have you know forty half written scripts
so I would suggest not to
that because I don't think you'll end up
finishing it whereas like I think if you
focus on the one and keep pushing
forward and if you feel like you're
really hitting a place that you can't do
it find somebody to write it with you
and if you do they'll help you get past
that and there's no shame in working
with a writing partner I think it's it's
actually like a really fulfilling and
creative experience that I again enjoy
much more than writing by myself going
back to the mist is a hundred thousand
by like an average that you might get it
really depends on the movie like its I
mean you could get like there's it's
such a sliding scale it's you know I
know people who better getting M G's
that are like you know over 3 million
but like I'm not getting those but I
know people who are so it's like you
know it's it's such a sliding scale it's
you know it's not always a hundred
thousand it's sometimes less sometimes
it's like you know twenty five thousand
sometimes it's you know three million so
it really just depends so you know I
think it depends on your package it
depends on what the market is looking
for at the time and it depends on you
know do they believe that you'll be able
to deliver on time and stuff like that
so and it depends on what cast you have
but I think concept is key for sure you
know if you have like a high concept
horror movie that is you know smart
contained and it has like a good cast
you can get you know a good mg when it
comes to horror action you're gonna get
a much bigger mg because action does
much bigger overseas and you need more
to be able to make the movie and you
know you'll have more towards a bigger
cast so I think you know the the other
thing is attracting actors to horror
movies is much harder so the key about
doing that for a horror movie and when
you're writing a horror movie is yes you
know create the beats create a smart
story have it be you know have scares in
it but don't just have them be like you
know cheap scares create real human
people with real human problems and on a
base level
figure it out as a drama a drama with
like you know horror elements and that's
how you're pitching it to the actors and
then you know how you're pitching it to
the distributor is that it's a
straight-up horror movie so you you're
kind of having both and you when you can
do both and the story works is both
that's when you're gonna have like a
stronger viability because you'll be
able to say these are characters I want
to play because if you have just like
your run-of-the-mill horror movie that
everybody else is making you're gonna
have every every agent and won't even
get it to their actors they'll look at
it and be like yeah this is just you
know another blah blah blah so you want
to be able to have it both be highbrow
but also appeal to the audience because
the horror audience specifically wants
you know certain things they want like
paranormal is really big right now they
want ghosts they want scares so you have
to be able to work that in while also
you know working with the actors in a
way because the actors don't want to
feel like they're making a horror movie
when you feel like you're making a
horror movie you start to think well
there's a whole bunch of really crappy
low-budget horror movies that never come
out and never do anything and the second
people start to think like that they're
not gonna try as hard or they're gonna
like you know kind of regret their
decision of being involved or looking at
it
so if you can flip it and and really
have them feel like they're doing
something and really be passionate about
doing something that isn't quite horror
but you also have to be able to sell it
to your distributor that it's a
straight-up horror movie does that make
sense look you know we get these calls
when hey do you have this you have that
Jim up the Horsham you know we're
looking for the next get out in my
opinion yeah it was more of a thriller
and so it's an interesting thing when
you start to deal with some of these
companies that are like well this is
what we're looking for you know we have
horror films and you know straight-up
horror films and but it it's that thing
now it's like everybody wants to get out
and to me every lot of scripts in that
just didn't seem like a horror film to
me so nobody want to get out before it
was get out
so like the thing is is like you have to
find the angle and sell it to the
distributor and sell them on the idea
that you know more than them without
making them feel that you know more than
them you can like hint towards it and
don't feel like don't like
make them think that you think that you
know more but think that they might have
just picked up on something that you
said and like you have an angle that
they might not have thought about but
like you're not like challenging their
ego at all because a lot of the times
it's like look these distributors and
like a lot of the times like the
gatekeepers that you will deal with
they're just selling linoleum like they
don't know the difference between this
and this they're doing the exactly they
can't tell you everybody wants something
that was just successful but they will
all reject that movie prior to it being
successful because it's risky so they
don't think that they know they just go
oh well you know this works because it's
this person and in this person and it's
you know a car blows up let's do that
you know so you have to be able to sell
them on why it's commercially viable and
why it's you know hitting the right
beats for them and I think that's I
think that's an important thing to do so
it's you know you you have to be able to
talk the language that they want to hear
and there's certain buzzwords that they
want to hear but also slip in that it's
a new angle on that and the the thing
about those buzzwords which is really
interesting is you know it's all
buzzwords that I don't know if they
heard it from like foreign buyers and
now they're saying it back to they're
like it's one of those things like I
don't know where the certain buzzwords
came from but now everybody just parrots
them and like if you go to like
something like AFM and you sit in these
you do like 20 meetings and everybody's
like you know what we want a
high-concept blah blah blah and you know
we want it to be elevated and it's like
what does that mean it's like you know
so it's you just have to say well it's
an elevated high concept you know horror
film so you know just use go into all
these meetings hear the buzzwords jot
them down and work them into your pitch
because I'm willing to bet you none of
them actually know what those things
mean they don't they're just using you
know I mean what they really want is if
you're able to say look you know it's
it's it's insidious meets you know The
Grudge they're like oh well those are
two movies that did really well oh yeah
this is great
you know so if you're able to pitch them
on like two things that they've heard of
that did well they're like oh wow well
that sounds great because that's I mean
again like a lot of it and I'm not
saying every distributor but a lot of it
and I've been fortunate enough remind
you I'm just saying I've been fortunate
enough to work with a lot of
distributors that actually get it just
saying like that actually know what
they're talking about in dealing with
but I have had meetings with many
distributors that have absolutely no
clue what they actually want and they're
just trying to follow somebody else's
trends so you have to also look at that
and be able to have those conversations
with them you might get lucky and meet
with like one of the really good
distributors that'll be like oh yeah
let's just make this because it seems
like it's gonna be cool but I mean are
you are you laying them I let them
decide what the budget is usually
because I don't want the thing is is I
don't want to come in with 1.5 and scare
them into thinking like oh well you know
I was only trying to make a movie for
500,000 but I also don't want to come in
with you know let's say five hundred
thousand and say well I was really gonna
be spending 1.5 on this so so like you
know just say that that you know the
budget is flexible and you know if they
ask to see you know a budget you say
okay I can prepare you know a budget for
you and put that together if you know
how to use movie magic budgeting and
scheduling like that that'll be your
friend for sure I say you know make a
couple different budgets but you know in
my experience the more steps they try
and make you go through the more that
they're not likely actually going to
make it the people that actually like
are going to make it and and want to get
the movie and need the content and have
you know like an output to fulfill or
whatever they have they're going to move
really quick I mean I've had times where
I was working with you know a
distributor or a you know or a company
where I was going in for the interview
and during the interview they were
talking about so you're shooting on this
day and it's like oh wait so wait hold
on well we're already moving and so you
have stuff like that happen because
it really is like the there's people
have output deals they have they have
stuff they have to fulfill and so if
they believe you could actually hit it
and what you're doing what is that noise
oh I was like oh it's it's where we're
doing the bird box thing it's like it's
like if this is the bird box so it's you
you have you have distributors that are
have you know either they have them
because the other thing is a lot of
these distributors are you know labels
being serviced by bigger distributors so
like people have you know like a output
with Sony or an output with Lionsgate er
and output with you know all these
things and they have a certain amount of
movies they have to deliver per year so
a lot of them will be like if they think
it works there they'll go for it so you
have to or if they think that they're
getting a bargain if they think like
well this is something that I would have
normally spent like three hundred
thousand for but I could get it for two
hundred great you know so you have you
have to you have to figure those things
out you're not giving them one sheets
right away you're just going no no if
they ask for it you know I'll put
something together but no no and mind
you a lot of it a lot of the time a lot
of the time I have been fortunate enough
to be hired on to as a producer at least
a lot of the time I've been fortunate
enough to be hired on to movies that
were already financed you know by
directors who already had outputs with
people or stuff like that and so I've
brought in after it was financed to do a
lot of the nuts and bolts producing of
like figuring out okay how you know what
are my big set pieces how do I get these
you know these locations how do I get
you know these actors how do I get this
camera package whatever it is how do I
hire the crew like what's the crew how
do I budget the actual film to make it
because you know usually whatever you
know top sheet you're sending them isn't
gonna make sense when you're actually
doing the real movie cuz things in flows
it's it's you know it changes as it goes
genre day
that's always a hit but hard to do is
horror comedy it's just far and few of
those
horror comedies a big hit on if you
could get like a big level of it the
problem with anything comedy based is is
from at least what distributors feel is
audiences don't respond to people they
don't already find funny so you have to
be able to get people you already find
funny in the movie like you know people
that everybody's like oh you know Seth
Rogen's hilarious if you could get like
people like that in your movie they'll
go for it but if it's you know if if
you're dealing with people that aren't
typically known as you know widely known
as comedians or whatever it's gonna be
harder and anything that's mixing genres
usually scares people on the distributor
end because they as I said like it's
it's it's linoleum sometimes so like in
their mind they they don't see the
difference they don't understand what
genre it is they're like but what is it
is it a horror movie or is it a comedy
they can't understand they'll be like
why is it funny here you notice I'm not
kidding I've experienced it so it's like
you know the you you have you they feel
like audiences won't respond so I think
the important thing is - you have to
think how your base audience is going to
react and then go from there but I think
yeah horror comedy I love horror
comedies I mean I think Shaun of the
Dead is great you know
Tucker and Dale vs. evil is awesome but
you know you have to have people that
people already find funny or you know in
that instance they just you know Shaun
of the Dead just you know hit hit
wildfire yeah as far as low budget I
mean ideally one saw came up with some
containing or to me was the king of
local educate but what are things
story-wise that you should be aware of
that will kick up your budget hugely
story-wise I mean having big set pieces
you know the bigger the movie feels so
CGI you would not I wouldn't say you
know
the problem is is on an indie level if
you rely too heavily on CGI it's gonna
look too much like a sci-fi Channel
movie you know and I'm not trying to
diss sci-fi at all they do their thing
and it's it's awesome but your
distributors are gonna think like that
because unless you have like listen if
you know the top CGI team and they're
doing all the Marvel movies and they're
willing to work with you and help you
out
then like you know great but I think
having big set pieces like you know you
know somebody who has a really giant you
know wooded ranch in the middle of
nowhere that it's just really awesome
and it's gonna look amazing on camera
and has a lot of texture on the walls
inside of it and it's all wood and it's
dilapidated and something right
something that fits that because you're
gonna be able to have really big looking
shots and that looks like money so when
they see your trailer and you show them
the pictures of this place they'll be
like oh wow this this looks like you
spent a lot of money so you have to find
things that other people aren't getting
that are bigger set pieces that look
like something you know nobody else has
you know finding a way to make it look
bigger the bigger the movie looks the
more interested that they're going to be
so if you could find ways to find stuff
that nobody's doing or you have
something like you know maybe you have
somebody who in your family that has
like a department store and it's like a
lot of texture and there's some cool
stuff when I say texture I'm saying like
no white walls because you lose degrees
of separation of your subject against a
white wall it's you you want to have you
know a lot of texture a lot of different
things in the background because if you
look at any of these big big-budget
studio movies you have a busy frame
there's a lot of different stuff in your
frame there's a lot there's a lot of art
to art design and art direction so the
production designs so the problem is is
on these lower budget movies you don't
really have as big of an art budget as
some of these bigger budget movies so
find locations that look like you do
because then you are able to disguise
and hide your budget and when you can
hide your budget and you don't have
people looking at your movie going you
know oh well he spent X amount of
dollars that's how you make something
that people want like on a level because
remember and a friend of mine
who I've worked with told me this which
which is really interesting the
difference between you know let's say
you're making a horror movie like for
instance my movie Bethany and you know I
there's I enjoyed my movie it was one of
my favorites I did but I have issues
with it now looking back I made it a few
years ago and you know one thing that he
said to me which which I completely
agree with the audience at home does not
know that that you know and don't care
that I spent you know X amount of
dollars on this movie they still have to
spend the same 399 to watch it as they
do to watch insidious so you have to be
able to hide your budget and not set
yourself up for failure put yourself in
a position where your movie is going to
be able to hold up in certain aspects
you know you're not going to make
insidious but don't make something that
you can't afford make something that you
can't afford and be smart with it and
put it in you know in perspective and
make it look bigger without showing what
your budget is because the second it
starts to feel low-budget and you start
to have you know bad lighting and bad
sound and bad all this stuff that's how
your movies going to stick out and
you're gonna have stuff where people are
like oh well you know they'll be upset
because you're you know it's the same
it's the same price of admission so you
have to find creative ways I think you
know it might be even harder on an indie
level because you have to find creative
ways to make your movie look way bigger
than it is
did you get to the point right I guess
you kind of jump to the point so my
question would be do you think that
someone should be like independently
trying to start a production company at
this point or just completely focus on
making films
don't worry about production side do not
well two things one unless your movie is
completely fully finished do not send it
to a film festival because even though
they say they will accept you know like
the unfinished movie don't send it
because you're basically asking you
don't know who's watching it and you're
asking somebody to imagine how you would
have actually done it when it's finished
so never do that never show somebody
your movie before it's finished
III mean I've had that bite me in the
ass way too many times where it's like
you'll show it to them and they'll be
like yeah but you know these green walls
are terrible and you're like well that's
because this is a like this is a green
screen moment like you know and there's
like oh well why did you send it like
that and it's like you know they it's
amazing and you guys will all experience
it when you show your edit to people to
get notes and you can preface it in the
beginning and say hey please it's it's
not color corrected it's the sound is
not done please only give comments on
story and and character nothing about
sound or color and you'll have people go
so what are you gonna do about the sound
like you know it doesn't sound really
good at this part and you're like
nothing about the sound but doesn't that
explain that it's such a multi-layered
cake yeah you know you just don't eat
one part of that layer of the cake you
just sort of take a bite and sound the
lightening script the acting all of that
comes together and so everyone get what
you're saying yeah just if I can back up
half a step you're what you were saying
about you know make the movies you can
afford I call that sort of like know
your boundaries ya know where your
target is and you just stay in your lane
and it's like okay this is what this
movie's gonna be and I think if you can
articulate that in the pitch meet people
understand that you're not trying to
overreach that you're going up there a
very specific target and if you can
articulate that well enough and they
understand yes that I can make money in
this precise zone that's where you get
these small movies that actually turn a
big budget yeah I definitely agree
and and you know when I said earlier not
setting yourself up for failure you know
if you only have $200,000 don't make a
war movie for God's sakes like you know
you'll and you'll see people that'll be
like oh yeah well you know now you're
going up against stuff like Saving
Private Ryan and so you're gonna be
compared to that so they're gonna say oh
well you know where are the five hundred
thousand extras on the like on the beach
live exaggeration but like where are all
the bomber jets and all this stuff so
you don't do stuff that sets yourself up
for failure the second you start
flagging things going hey look I don't
have the money to actually make this
movie is the second you actually will
have people going well this is crap and
you don't want people to do that because
you you have that's the reaction and it
sucks that that's the reaction they
won't see oh well you know you had all
these other cool elements they will just
see what's missing so do not set
yourself up for failure just don't do it
it's a horrible thing and believe me
when I say set yourself up for failure
it really will set yourself up for
failure if you do stuff like that
because it's it's it will never measure
up to the other movies that it's
supposed to measure up to so I think
being successful in doing this is
setting yourself up for you know not
setting yourself up for failure the
other thing that I've you know learned
as well is and now I'm being honest with
you guys and obviously being being
filmed saying stuff but don't tell
people your budgets because you know I I
had a very long stint of being stuck
doing you know hundred fifty thousand
dollar movies because I kept saying you
know I kept thinking I'd go into a
meeting when I was being hired for a
movie saying like hey you know and I
made this movie for a hundred fifty
thousand and it looks great and they
look at it be like oh yeah this is great
and then they go well you do great with
150 thousand so let's give you a hundred
fifty thousand and it's like oh well
crap yeah yes so it's like you know it's
you you get stuck so do not tell them
just say under a million
don't tell them the budget because also
you know it's it's especially if you're
trying to sell it to a distributor that
hasn't bought it yet like and you've
already finished the movie don't tell
them the budget because the second you
do they're gonna be like oh well you
know I can pay way less so just just
don't don't talk about your budgets and
the other thing is like unless you know
the people really well and it's like
other filmmakers that you know don't
don't even tell people the budgets
because people will start to talk and
say hey like you know he's making these
movies for this much and then like it
somehow gets around it's it's it's a
business where people like you know
parrot things so so just don't don't
tell people your budgets yeah yeah they
he said something about it and we're
like yeah like he's like what do you
have to recoup about this and we were
like and I could see one of the guys
going and he was about to say how much
we made for him
do not but it to make so they it doesn't
matter how much did you say what do you
think I made it for okay and then if
they say hey well you know I think you
made it for you know two million you
know and you've really made it for a
million say yeah about that if they
think you made it for you know let's say
no we made it for more but like don't
tell them your budget
don't tell them your budget because they
their job is to try and lowball you
their job is you know like it's it's
like it's like you're thinking you're
buying a used car at auction so like
they're trying to they're trying to
haggle you and the second you start
negotiating against yourself is the
second you've already lost so do not do
that do not negotiate against yourself
they call the straight now
people say it's a lot easier to get for
those it's a lot and I'm just and I'm
not saying this in a negative way but
this is what we're hearing is that we
have a couple of movies out there right
now that some people are getting ready
to make that one's a comedy [ __ ]
but we sold it as Mean Girls meet Friday
the 13th so it was you know mean
something that but it's like I've seen a
lot of horror films now lately that are
very high concept like they're not like
I actually love that that was freaky to
me but then I've also gone a lot of it
so much doesn't seem very very poor
quality and they're just going
everywhere I mean do they all have like
names in know and I you know and and I
yes maybe some
doctors are kind of known for the staff
safety wrote and directed it but it's so
you know and and knowing some of the
budget and do you think it's easier
together the more it's a folding period
I'm gonna touch on a couple things that
you said first I'm gonna go on the film
festivals thing I would not go off of
what you see at film festivals as what's
commercially viable and what what will
sell you know unless it's like a
Sundance
you know because Sundance like you know
those are like TIFF or anything but
beyond that like all these other film
festivals and I'm not trying to knock on
any of them I think it's cool to get
exposure and stuff but it's a lot about
who you know not how good the movie is
so you will you you know every Film
Festival you know it's you get a lot of
people that will you know put in like oh
well you know my friend made a movie so
let's put that in or like let's this
person you know made this movie that was
really big so they worked on this let's
put them in or this person has this big
actor in it let's just put it in like so
you you there's a lot of experience of
that so I think there's like a trap of
of that as well and just because the
tricky thing about horror is like you
might have a bunch of horror movies that
get really really talked about and like
you know because they seem like really
crazy and this and that but that's not
like actually what is selling the most
of the horror movies what actually has
the most DVD sales or rentals or the
biggest buys from Netflix and stuff like
that you have to look at you know what
the most exposed movies are what what
when you go to you know Walmart or Best
Buy is on the store shelves what is you
know and what has the most copies on the
store shelves like the moat the biggest
the biggest you know spread at a Best
Buy or a Walmart or whatever you know
what is the most out there because
that's what's getting the bigger
distribution you might see you know some
of these smaller movies you know in
different places but if they're not
getting to like a Netflix or like a Hulu
it doesn't really mean that they're
doing that big so I think it's important
to to know that yeah I think cuz you
know there's a lot of smaller
distributors within
that will pick up horror movies but you
know it doesn't mean that they're doing
numbers so I think it's important to
know for sure and is it true that you I
mean now that we're you know and we're
going out to actors now you that's
fascinating that you just do that stuff
laughing to people that you think are
funny because some of the people that
are casting directors going out to I
don't necessarily think they're funny
they're just really high on the
Instagram meter or this kind of things
this is what we keep getting from some
of these things if I hear that one more
time while their members are you know
they've got these many followers okay
just so you know is that with the
casting directors saying are your
distributor distributor likes it like we
give them a list oh we you know we have
a list of people they go we like this
business girl because she's you know and
it's just Anna even for horror which I
definitely give you a distributor what
they want if they want something because
you don't want them to ever be able to
point to something and say well I wanted
you to do this and you didn't do it and
that's why the movie didn't do well so
like you yeah but but the the
interesting thing is like I mean the
Instagram numbers and Twitter numbers
like that that stuff doesn't do anything
it doesn't do anything because you know
people around the country aren't only
looking at Twitter and Instagram people
going into stores that are still buying
stuff and mind you like anybody who
tells you that DVD and blu-ray is not
selling anymore they're lying to you it
really is so like you know and or you
know VOD is still selling people rent
stuff so if they're looking for if
they're looking at a comedy and they're
going to want to watch somebody that
they recognize so you know unless you're
gearing let's say Instagram
unless you're gearing towards that's a
very small demo that's a younger
demographic you know you're not going
you're not it's not good to go for that
you know you might want to throw that in
there like you might want to throw a you
know a person in there but you're gonna
want to stack them with you know
commercially viable people as well you
know that way you're hitting each
demographic
ya know just does that make sense that
makes absolute I just figured that
closer like maybe if you want to bring
in some younger people sure you know I
mean the thing about horror is horror is
all concept based if you have a really
cool concept you know and and your
distributor is happy with you know the
budget range and they're already
financing it and you have a cool concept
you're gonna do okay you know but the
hook you have to have a cool hook and a
cool concept and like if that if that if
that reads and that plays it's gonna be
cool but you know and the cool box art
works as well but the one thing you
really want to focus on though is I
think you know you want to be able to
separate from the pack and how you
separate from it is you have you know a
good cast and having a good cast of
people that will be recognized and so
like you know people want to watch
people they know so finding that and
even if they don't have giant roles
finding those people and putting them in
the movie works and on the box and and
hitting those hitting each demographic
so yeah maybe throw in an Instagram
person if you're trying to get like you
know teenagers to watch the movie but
also you're gonna want you know stuff
like that that other people would know
think about you know who else is is is
you know known by everybody and the best
way to do it and to figure that out
really is don't don't you know go well I
know this person cuz you you work in
film you might know all these names you
know ask people who don't work in film
like hey have you heard of this person
and this person in this person and see
how they respond you know ask a bunch of
people and say hey which of these three
actors do you like and just ask because
then like you know you'll be surprised
at how many people have no clue who
those people are or like you know a
couple of them aren't so start to start
to you know do that game and I think
it'll help you but the distributor
probably gave you a list because they've
they've ranked people on a list and
they're like these are a names of B
names C names right
so I mean some of the a names are always
ridiculous - right it's like hey let me
get somebody that's completely
unreasonable like hey we want Brad Pitt
and it's like oh yeah well if we could
get Brad Pitt like you know why would we
be doing it with on a very low budget
level we
we'd be doing with something like a much
higher budget level like it's like so
yeah the horror I didn't realize that it
was so much about a name well it's not
it's not so much about a name like you
can get your horror movie done with a
concept but I think the name is what's
gonna separate you from the pack you
know because like having the names will
separate you from the pack versus just
being like a run-of-the-mill horror
movie and what you want to do is you
know what is going to make somebody
click on your movie when they're
scrolling down on VOD over somebody
else's because are they actually going
to watch your trailer or are they just
going to see the box you know are they
gonna are they walking in the store
shelf are they just gonna see the box
and they see a name they recognize you
have to be able to separate and set
yourself up in the best way possible I
call that three seconds three seconds to
tell everybody to show everybody not
even tell show your thumb what this
movie is about yeah I've heard that many
times from from distributors they say 30
seconds they're moving on yep they say
that exact thing I actually had a
distributor that changed the title of
one of my movies because they said it
didn't explain what the what the movie
was and so the problem is is you know as
a creative you want to only focus on the
art but film is where you know Commerce
meets art so you have to think of both
sides of it and you have to be amenable
to both sides because you have to be
able to think of the commerce because if
you don't think of the Commerce you're
probably going to have a hard time being
able to get stuff off the ground or you
know doing them multiple times you know
so it's important to think of the
Commerce and to think of how the movie
is going to do and how people outside of
the movie that you're making will feel
about the movie so you think about that
for sure I think it's important do you
ever like I mean I don't know about now
because nobody like movies but maybe
you're starting off like well cuz I'm
finding my
you probably like nectar something but
like the ever liked Ella you're like
your DP or like whoever's gonna help
y'all hey I don't got that much money to
pay you guys but if like if I make money
under you know cuz they're gonna be
working for like three weeks or from
them and you can't pay them you like you
ever like like trying to deal with them
like hey yeah yeah I mean you're gonna I
don't know like you're gonna want to
make whatever you can do you're gonna
want them wheel and deal and make
whatever deals you can to get the movie
made and the people that are going to
agree to do that movie with you are the
people that are trying to build their
resume as well so you know I don't think
there's any shame in doing that but like
you know don't try and convince you know
some huge person to do it for that and
sell them on it like a dream on that you
know you you want to you're working with
the people that you know are on the
level with you and you build with them
so you know it's not it's not
unreasonable or you could find somebody
that like you know let's say an actor
that typically does you know comedy and
you're like hey I'm doing a drama you
might be able to get you know them to do
a serious drama because they haven't
been able to show that side of them so
you can cast against type sometimes to
get like you know bigger actors to do a
lower budget movie because you could
give them the opportunity to do
something that nobody's ever seen them
do and they will think oh well I want to
be able to show that I could do that
because that'll get me into the room for
XYZ later and I could use that footage
and blah blah blah and it's only like a
couple days of my life so you can do
that but as far as crew these people are
trying to build their resumes so I you
know I think it's it's it's not wrong to
ask if they're building you know the
resumes but also you know you can't
demand endless amounts of their time as
well so you have to be you know
cognizant of that but you want to get
people that are down for the cause for
sure I'm like right now what I kind of
do is I'm either working or spending am
i animate working on the next movie you
know what I mean I'm at like that phase
it was the point where you start like
focusing on you know starting your up
like - you start over
company or do you just keep making
movies until someone's like hey I like
your movies can I hire you to make me I
mean I I've had a couple production
companies before I don't currently I you
know I kind of a lot of the time you're
making like you know a new LLC for each
movie anyway so you know I wouldn't
really be focused on a production
shingle I've as myself I've just branded
you know a James cullin Bret film on my
movies and that's like the branding that
I do for my movies I want to direct yeah
as a director and then you know as a
producer I'm with the PGA so I put like
the little PGA stamp next to my name
when I when I produce and like that's my
branding and that's what I focus on and
I don't care about having a production
shingle in the beginning of the movie or
anything like that
some people do so it depends on if you
care about that you could you know put
up with it you could you could put
together an LLC that you have to keep up
but you know typically every movie
you're gonna create a new LLC anyway so
I think you know I I wouldn't really
focus too much on it yeah and then also
you know I've kind of dabbled in all
different things I've gotten him off the
ground myself I've also been hired to do
a lot of movies I remember the first
time I was hired to do my first movie
you know I was offered $1,000 to direct
this movie the first time I was hired
and I was like wow $1,000 so somebody
wants I was like 19 years old and I was
like somebody wants to pay me to do this
wow this is cool
so I was like 10 days shoot and I was
like thousand bucks this is awesome
like I can make a thousand dollars in 10
days that's crazy so you know I've made
more since then but what I'm trying to
say is you know going back to like film
as a muscle like look if if you want to
work on stuff and you want to do stuff
great
I've actively tried to do stuff outside
of my genre and I will take less money
to do stuff outside of my genre because
I want to be able to like try it and
play in different genres and stuff I
think it's important to work and build
so I think you know I wouldn't be so
much focused on the production company
as I would about the work you know go
out and you know shop that movie around
you know try and get a job trying the
other thing is try and get a job on
somebody else's movie as a director
after you've directed because
working for somebody is very different
than working for yourself and you have
to learn the difference and you have to
experience it as well because when you
have people to answer to you have to
learn how to play nice and learning how
to play nice is going to really help you
move forward in this business because
there's I I think somebody I don't know
who said it maybe it was my dad but they
said you know in this business you could
either be oh so clever or oh so pleasant
and sometimes I I recommend being
pleasant and that's that's the truth you
know people like to work with the people
they like so you know being able to not
be argumentative while still being
passionate and getting your things
across is an art form so find a way to
get people passionate about what you're
passionate about without being
disrespectful because the people that
are above you have hired you and they
are if you do a good job they will hire
you again and if you are easy to work
with they will hire you again so find a
way to walk the line of being passionate
while also not you know being a [ __ ]
basically because believe me I've been
on the other side of things as a
producer and you will be like why are
these people being so irrational like I
it's it's it's it's very easy when
passionate to to completely lose sight
of how you're behaving and because I
mean you could watch like you know
what's why people think sometimes
directors are crazy you you will see
like you you'll start to go crazy
because you start to obsess about little
things so you have to find a way to be
passionate as well as like you know
friendly and fun in the same thing so I
think that's important so I I recommend
at all times if possible even if it's
just like a youtube video or something
find a way to work for somebody else and
just experience it because I think
that's that's the kind of you know
experience that you should have when
moving forward because when you're
trying to get these bigger jobs later
which I'm still trying to get mind you I
haven't but I know it the things in the
past that I've done are going to help me
because I know like look I'm not going
to throw a hissy fit and have a fight
over you know a couple things that
aren't that important I will stand my
ground and explain you know why but if
you know if they put their foot down
you know that's it you have to allow the
people on top to to make some of those
decisions because ultimately they are on
the top until you are you know a carte
blanche director that's doing giant
things you have to learn to play nice
with everybody
then I mean if you have all the rights
to do anything in the world you could be
like you know you know a not sewer that
does whatever they want at any point
that's my thought I don't know two
positives negatives the negatives of I'm
never going to do that again um top two
things I learned directly top two things
I learned directing that I would do
again I mean definitely the
pre-production stuff I'm obsessed with
making my movie in prep like I do color
coded notes I draw I do color coded
notes for every department I'll like you
know right I pre direct the movie in the
script I write all these notes and then
I'll sit with my department heads and go
through and point out all the things I
talked about so that we could actually
be on the same page and talk about that
so everything is figured out I think
that is you know I don't know how I
could ever made a movie without it so I
think that's number one number two for
me is you know I think being
collaborative as a director being
collaborative you know because I
remember my first couple movies you know
I was the director I would be damned if
somebody was gonna tell me what to do
because it's like what you know I'm the
director why do you care and then
realizing like oh well you know no
everybody's here for the same goal to
make a movie I'm gonna be collaborative
with my department heads and realizing
like they're just trying to do their
jobs too and collaborating with actors
is one of the best experiences I've ever
had
you know because I might have my ideas
about a character even if I wrote the
script but it's amazing to see what you
know everybody comes with a bag of tools
and they they're like oh well I could do
this and I could do this and it's really
amazing to see cuz you know youth right
and throw you
ideas about the character at the canvas
and they throw their ideas about the
character at the canvas and whatever
works for both of you you used to paint
the picture of who this person is and so
you build this character and you'll
people will bring up things that you
never thought about and you'll be like
wow that's amazing and you know you'll
have a moment where you you know I had a
moment in in one of my movies where you
know shannen doherty had this long
speech about like why she was you know
upset that with her daughter because she
saw you know all her hopes and dreams
were being thrown away and she was you
know she saw herself and her daughter
and like you know although she was aging
her daughter was so beautiful so she was
also jealous and instead of this long
speech that I had written and I spent
all this time you know Shannon was just
like crying cried and just like looked
at her and she did it in a look and
that's not something that I would have
thought about it unless you know and
that look said everything so I think you
know there's there's moments where you
have that and I think being
collaborative and doing that it's it's
great because you see things that you
don't always think about things that I
would never do again as a director I
will never ever work with a DP that I
have not spent time with prior to
filming the movie because the difference
between being collaborative and having
somebody who literally just thinks they
know better within you and will not have
a conversation is a horrible experience
where you're like hey I want to set up
for this shot and like now we're gonna
do this shot because then like when you
have it when you have a rift with your
DP you realized very quickly that your
DP has two departments on their side
that you do not have so I think that's
definitely you know something I would
never do again is I need to sit down
with my DP you know have a bunch of
conversations in pre-production any
argument that I'm gonna have with my DP
I want to have it before the movie
starts so that we're just clockwork on
set and it's boom boom boom so I I would
never do that again
another thing that I would never do
again is I'd say probably work with an
act
that I haven't talked to and met with as
well because I've had people that I've
cast before in movies that I'm like nah
they'd be great and like blah blah oh
yeah oh uh let's get him and then you
know they just show up and they just do
not give a [ __ ] and it's like you know
okay well so like I need to meet with
and talk with this person and sell them
on the passion of this movie before
they're ever there or else if I don't
like I can't have them coming in blind
and being like you know you know
whatever I'm just going through the
motions because you know you you have
people that now mind you I respect a lot
of actors but you will have people that
are just doing it for a paycheck and
they're just going through the motions
and you know if that's the case and you
you're being forced to use that first
person by the distributor I at least
want to know it first I don't want to
figure that out on set because that's a
really horrible experience to have yeah
definitely I mean not only do I do that
with my DP my DP you know we'll watch
movies together and I'll point out why I
like certain shots and stuff like that
also you know I'll create a collage of
different pictures from other movies
that I like and then off of that because
I love shooting on Alexa which is like
the greatest camera there is just I love
it
we actually create our own LUT and so
you know I have that LUT fed to my
monitor so that I'm able to you know see
exactly what I'm exposing for so it
actually moves much quicker in color too
because we're we're lighting for a
certain look that we've already decided
on and we're going for that instead of
just using this standard you know
whatever we're actually going for a
specific look and I think it's you know
it really helps and it's you know we're
on the same page there so I think I
think that's good the other thing I'm
going to say while speaking about looks
and and and color and horror do not be
afraid of having your subjects go into
darkness a lot of people will just light
everybody very flat and you want to have
mood you want to have cuts on people's
faces so you have shadow
do not be afraid of having somebody like
dip in and out of darkness because
that's what real life is and that's how
people are going to be scarier but it
also creates an atmosphere atmospheric
look and that's important that's
important because you don't want to just
look like a TV movie you want to you
know separate from the pack so you want
to have something that looks more
artistically driven you know and and
although you are selling a horror movie
if you're making something that feels
like you know a dark fantasy or a family
drama or of this like look at hereditary
even though hereditary is a you know a
horror movie it is at a core level a
family drama and it you know that when
they were making that movie you know the
director had to be talking about how
it's a family drama and into this and
it's this even though you're making a
horror movie you are gearing towards you
know real palpable human things and
that's important brother credits Harry
which struck me about that is sound
yes horror seems to be more audio
centric than maybe some of the others
that are out there yeah sound design
it's huge is huge i I I've been very
fortunate that I work with like a really
great sound design team they've worked
on you know Netflix movies and blum
house movies that they're they're
fantastic so they help with a lot of
guidance on that but you know there's a
lot of stuff where you you'll say like
okay you sit with them and do a spotting
session and you'll talk through
everything so you'll say okay right here
you know I want this here I want this
like I'm thinking like I want to hear
something that's you know like a
screeching noise here and so you you'll
walk through everything with them then
you'll do a review session and try and
you know work it from there but it's
important to develop you know what you
want to hear and talk with them and
articulate that so I think you know for
me what I do is even though like I'm not
you know a genius with that kind of
stuff I collect a whole bunch of sound
effects online and put in like sound
effects throughout my entire edit so
that like I have stuff so I'm like okay
this is these are the moments where I
want to hear stuff and I want you to
fill in pass this but these are the most
important things and I want to do your
own version of this and this so it's
important to be able to do that and the
thing about making a movie is
communication
so if it's something like sound or if
it's something like music and like let's
say you're not you don't know a lot
about music you didn't go to like music
academy or whatever find ways to
articulate it without you know knowing
those knowing per se like okay you know
I don't want like a minor chord here
like if you're not talking about that
find ways to articulate it by going okay
well I want it to be scary and I want it
to sound like this and here's like a
tempt score moment of something
I'm not saying to copy this but I'm
saying like this is the emotion that I'm
trying to capture and I like the
instruments that are used here so find
ways to talk about it in ways that you
understand and that you can articulate
to them but sound is I mean sound is all
dependent on what you do for the movie
yeah but also horror is all about
building tension so part of it is if you
notice horror movies will build a lot of
tension the music will start to rise the
sound effects will start to rise and
then it drops out so it gives you a
breath for a moment and then boom it
hits you and then but it'll hit you like
not that hard so like it's like a jump
and then all of a sudden like a couple
seconds later it'll hit you again
and if you watch almost every horror
movie uses these patterns because it
lulls you into a false sense of security
making you think that you just got
scared when they're actually building up
for the real scare right here so it's
you know it's you it's tension and
release tension and release so a lot of
that is done with audio but it's also
done with editing so you'll see like you
know you'll go to a lot of how you edit
the movie when it comes to horror is is
to build tension so you know you you go
against the grain so if you've you've
just gone from a really Cuddy scene
where the shots cut a lot and then
suddenly you're in a scene that's very
very slow moving and it's like you know
you're not cutting and you're in a long
Steadicam shot your audience will start
to feel uneasy because it's it's against
what they were just doing before so it's
about turning people against what they
have just experienced so it's a
push-pull it's non-stop so horror but
visually and audio Lee is you want to do
a push pull you want to have them so
let's say one scene is very you know
very robust with music the next scene
you have you know just like a light
sound effect in the background and
that's it and it feels bare suddenly
like people are like okay something
weirds gonna happen so you find ways to
like play with them and trick them by
doing that with audio as well as with
you know visuals and try and have your
visuals match what you're doing with
audio or have it go against the grain
sometimes you'll have some really great
moments like for instance insidious that
tip the the Tiny Tim song tiptoe through
the window is super creepy but it's not
a creepy song if you listen to it
normally but it's super creepy against
what's going on in the movie so finding
something that's not normally creepy and
making it creepy I think also you know
freaks people out so you have to find
you know what what matches and what goes
against the grain or what doesn't and
and and play with it it's I think it's a
lot of experimentation and it's a lot of
you know trying that but I think the
push-pull of making a movie in the
horror genre I think is what really
helps because you have to you have to
play with the audience not only do you
have to give them what they want but
also give them what they don't think
they want and also trick them into
thinking something's going to happen
when it isn't and then hit them with
something when they don't think
something's gonna happen if that makes
sense
communication yes I agree so as a
producer / director how do you maintain
those communication with giving you push
back DP that basically not giving you
any you know respect I had that I had
that experience once sure and it was
horrible and I did not handle it that
well I was 20 years old and I did not
handle it that well so you know I think
I would handle it much better now but
communication is you know I a lot of
people just want to feel respected
within a position so you know
communication is allowing people to feel
like they're not being strangulated I
think if you if you allow people to feel
like they are being respected and you
want them to be creative and do their
job and then you harness their abilities
as well as like you know if you're
really good sometimes you can
figure out ways to you know have you
know collaborate but as well as you know
if you if you don't like what somebody's
doing and you want them to do something
that you want you're able to sometimes
convince them that your idea is their
idea which helps as well but I think
communicating for me is you know you you
establish way upfront you know hey we're
making this movie together anytime you
want to talk pull me aside let's chat as
long as I'm not in the middle of a taker
in the middle of this like let's do it
let's talk about what's moving forward
never never be afraid to you know allow
those open lines of communication with
all your department heads because it's
important to be able to endlessly
communicate about that because the most
important thing is being on the same
page and sometimes people will tell you
that they understand you when they don't
so it's important to really make sure
that they yeah okay great oh yeah yes so
it's like you know you say okay so let's
talk about it let's work it out and
sometimes you really want to have that
you know actors do want to be directed
they want to have those conversations so
if people aren't on the same page it's
okay it's okay if somebody doesn't
understand you and I think part of what
I always tell people is like it's okay
if you don't understand what I'm saying
if you notice I'll say like you do you
get what I mean because it's it's
ultimately you want to make sure that
they understand and that you're on the
same page because you know the film
industry is the only industry that I've
ever you know experienced where you can
say hey you know I
this is crude layman terms this hasn't
actually happened but it's just to put
it on a level of like you know you could
be like hey I I want a water and then
somebody will come back with a diet coke
and be like oh I got you your drink and
you'll be like no I needed a water and
they're like oh well it's you know I oh
I thought you wanted to die coke and
it's like you know you'll you'll
experience that a lot so it's like
people like kind of half listen so I
think it's like you know finding those
moments where you pull somebody aside
you have a conversation you keep it kind
of very private and internal and you say
hey blah blah blah like a lot of when
I'm talking to my actors I pull my
actors aside and I'll just have a
conversation with them and I'll just be
like you know very quietly like hey you
know what I really wanted to do was this
and you know I'm thinking like we could
try this
you keep your voice in your Tambor low
so they don't feel like they're being
embarrassed in front of anybody and like
you know you have those moments you give
the direction and then you send them
back or you know if it's just a really
minor adjustment where you're like hey
you know you could you know say it from
monitor you could be like hey I just
want to do it again but like guys let's
speed it up you know it depends on what
the direction is but if it's like if if
it's a conversation pull people aside
having a sidebar because you don't want
people to ever feel embarrassed or
disrespected the second that happens
that's when egos get involved when egos
aren't involved it's when we're just
having like a quiet conversation off to
the side most people are really easy
one-on-one and so you have those
experiences and as long as you don't get
heated with people it's you're not gonna
have issues usually that's my experience
did that answer your question yeah no I
just wanted to see you know why did you
expand in your thought that's all
because I think it's only an onset
situation it can happen through
pre-production and go in post
yeah well post-production yeah
post-production is a whole different
animal which you know I've had strange
experiences in post for sure but I think
you know it's it's important to make
people feel heard I mean I've had things
with producers where they want to do
certain things in the movie and we talk
about it I think the most important
thing like for for me when I'm directing
a movie is I'm like okay let me show you
everything that I was trying to do and
then from there if we've got to make
changes let's make up but it's like the
only thing that's confusing sometimes is
when people are trying to change stuff
and you're like well this is the rough
cut I haven't even done my edit to it
like I'm I'm just showing it to you now
because you wanted to see it but it's
not done yet like if we can just wait to
like we've locked you know because these
scenes are just stuff that is
placeholders so I think once you get to
a point where you're like okay you know
this is this is how I view the movie if
somebody's like well let's change this
and let's do this it's like okay let's
talk about it let's do that but I think
it's you know a lot of you know in a
producer's standpoint it's a lot of like
stepping back for a moment letting
somebody have their creative bounds and
then once they've done that and they
feel like they've been able to show it
then I think
people are more amenable to changes for
sure I think that you know that's that's
definitely from my experience as both a
director and as a producer when I
produced other people's films because
you know like I'm I don't want to sit in
on a directors movie and say hey you
know let's you should this is a bad take
of actor like change it because they're
like oh well you know I'm still working
on it like so you know sometimes you'll
see stuff but let I you let people tweak
it because you don't know have they even
gone through that scene yet or is that
just a scene that like the editor has
been doing you know mind you like if
anybody shows you and says hey look I've
done this is my like as close to my
director's cut as it's gonna be
and then they start flipping out about
like you know getting notes then they're
a crazy person you know but like if they
if they if they have if they have not
done it and they're like hey look like
you know give me like two more weeks so
I get it to where it needs to be and
then you know let's talk about it like I
think that's that's a completely
different thing but I think it's also
important to like make sure you know
let's say you're producing and you're
working with a director or you're
writing and producing and you're working
with a director or you know you're a
director working with you know a
producer or whatever make sure you are
on the same page at multiple points now
what I experienced as a director is I I
worked with a producer recently and it
was it was a good experience for me the
producer you know wanted to give his to
sense of like a lot of a time but mostly
what he really wanted to do is he just
wanted to know why I was making certain
decisions and as long as I was able to
say oh well I'm doing it because of this
and like I was able to tell him he
didn't really have a problem but like
it's it's I think you know when you have
the prep work and you're showing the
prep and you're actually explaining
things and you're not just saying like
well it's green because I feel like it's
green like it's you know if you're not
just arbitrarily making random decisions
and it doesn't feel like you know just
random things being thrown in the air
like a crazy person I think you know it
people can understand if you can make
people understand the vision a lot of
people are on board with that nobody
wants to really fight against you know
making something that they understand
and think is going to be good it's final
cut
pictures that you've directed always the
producers yeah I mean like I've I've you
know you know I've had I've had I've had
you know mind you like if I'm the sole
producer or one of the main producers I
end up with final cut but if I'm hired
by somebody they have to they have a
final cut but like as you know if I am
you know if I'm the guy who raised the
money and put the movie together and I'm
directing it you know I'm gonna have
final cut you know but it's it's it's
you know it depends you know it depends
on that really but you know even even
when I even on Bethany where like you
know I raise I help raise the money and
I wrote it and I you know well i
co-wrote it and I directed it I still
was taking notes for my producers and
stuff because the other thing is like
did you did you get final cut on that I
didn't take final cut on it I got notes
from my producers and a couple of them I
was like hey look I don't really like
this note I don't think it makes sense
like you know can we can we cut this out
and not do this and we had a
conversation we didn't do it but I
actually opened it up to notes because
I'm a firm believer and and a lot of
people might accent's might not make
sense to an audience because I might
have the entire story in my head and I
may be like well they're doing this
because of this and like blah blah blah
blah and it's this and they're like yeah
but that doesn't come across in the
story and if everybody doesn't
understand that in the story and you do
that's an issue so you should open it up
to people I think it's I I think working
in a vacuum is is ridiculous I mean
that's my I feel like film is more of a
collaborative thing so working in a
vacuum for me doesn't feel right because
I think it's important to open up these
you know the the dialogues with people
because if you wrote it and you're
directing it and you're producing it and
you've been living with this movie for
six months or however long maybe a year
maybe two years it's got everything in
it it's gonna make sense to you every
single thing is gonna make sense to you
and you know that's that's an issue
because it may not
make sense to everyone else but you have
to admit there there must be those
moments where you are just working with
people and you go there dopes they have
no idea I believe me I've had that and
I've found ways to I've found especially
when I've been hired to do stuff but I
found ways to address their notes while
still keeping things intact or I've been
able to calmly and you know assuredly
explain why I didn't want to do said no
because X but if they push back and say
well it has to be done you find a way to
get it done but I mean ultimately you
know I think yeah I mean listen you've
gotten I've gotten ridiculous notes
before I've literally gotten notes on a
movie like I said where you know the
it's people where it's obviously shot on
a green screen and they're you know
flipping out about the fact that it
looks green and it's like well you know
there's visual effects like let's wait
but and like you know you have to
explain that and stuff but you know one
of the best things to do is like
especially in pre-production it's like
find you know find a person that's like
a friend that you can just call up and
like vent for like five minutes and be
like and then you calm down and then you
type the email saying okay yeah let's
try that you know because like it's
sometimes people need to vent and I
think it's you know you if as long as
you get it out of your system then you
can move forward because as an artist
your knee-jerk reaction and will always
be like oh man like I don't want to do
that but you you you will find a way to
move past that I think it's important to
find a way to have those dialogues it's
my thought process do you think you're
working on the national your desire you
didn't work on you what yeah
but you're not leaving are you every
time I do a horror movie I say it's my
last horror movie ya know I'll probably
continue doing horror movies I love
[ __ ] it's like I mean I've got horror
movie tattoos all over me I'm like you
know but uh ya know I mean I'm trying
different different genres the problem
is is within horror it's like to get the
really really really big budget movies
which is my real goal you have to do
other genres you know my real goal is to
do like bigger studio level films and
like you got to get that through other
genres a lot of the time like I'm making
movies right now obviously independently
is that still a good path to be able to
like uh those people that wanted you to
PA for them like you know me people who
are working in actual movies that are
actually making money rather than I mean
I think if you make a viable product and
like you know you shop it and you start
networking with other filmmakers you
know I think that's the way to do it you
know yeah I mean you could make you know
III ended up producing a movie for
somebody who piayed for me before and
stuff so you do have those experiences
but I mean and it's good to meet other
people and stuff but you don't want to
fall into the trap of like that's your
livelihood because you might get stuck
doing that if that's what you you know
if that's what you you look at you know
it depends yeah I don't know where you
are but I mean I don't I don't recommend
it and I don't I'm not against it either
it's it's you know it's not the path I
would go but it doesn't mean that it
won't work yeah well I mean there is
that's the thing is there is no path
like it's like anybody tries to tell you
oh you have to do this to do that to do
with this like it's certain things work
for people certain things don't so it
could work and it could not it's I mean
it's all up to you know are you you know
work for you and and so it could work
for you it could so I'm not gonna say
don't do it
but you know it's not the path I would
choose but that doesn't mean you know
that doesn't really mean it should yeah
I know it's kind of like a non-answer
yeah
yeah I mean look nobody has nobody has
like the the keys to the kingdom and the
secret you know we're all we're all
bouncing ideas off of each other trying
to figure out what's what
so it's you know nobody has the exact
answers for everything yeah it's certain
things work and then certain things know
sometimes you make like a small movie
that you know does nothing and sometimes
you make a paranormal activity like you
know things happen so it's there is no
rule there's just exceptions to some
rule somebody made a long time ago
for like a horror movie yeah yeah well I
mean I think the trailers for the horror
movie like a lot of the time when I'm
making like the movie I think about you
know what's going to be in my trailer so
you know I'll think like okay you know I
need to have like this is like my money
shot this is like a Gore shot this is of
this so you kind of want to have these
like montage moments of like really cool
things that like are gonna hook the
audience and give them a glimpse without
like giving away too much about the
movie so I think you know figuring out
those moments in those shots --is is I
think very important so you know it
depends on what your movie is what kind
of horror movie it is if it's you know
if it's a ghost movie you want to show
like you know maybe a little bit of the
ghost possibly and like you know a
creepy looking house and and you know
you have to think like as as an audience
what do they look for when they want to
watch a horror movie and your trailer
should match that and hit those beats
and also have like a lot of stingers and
stuff like that you want to have like
boom boom boom boom talking about what
you said on have you ever shot at me
like thanks Joe
but it's like attic you know the
treatment but not putting the movie I've
done that before yeah I've done that
before I've done I've used elongated
coverage from something that I didn't
quite make the cut
I've done that but mostly I try to use
what's in the movie just because as an
audience member I've gotten frustrated
where I've seen something in a trailer
where I want to see that that's cool and
then it's not in the movie I'm like ah
man so I but yeah oh to go back on a
question that was asked earlier so my
first movie the biggest mistake that I
made on my first movie is I did the
entire thing and I was like well I wrote
it I directed it I produced it so after
being edited well it's done and so like
I did not you know it was like a
two-hour movie I should have cut out
like 30 minutes if not 40 minutes out of
this movie but I was like well I'm you
know I'm not I'm not removing these
scenes because I made it it was my first
time so so don't be afraid to cut stuff
out that's that's definitely you know
that was an 18 year old me mistake that
none of you
meg sometimes you just got to pull out a
scene one of my favorite things to do
now is I'll go through a scene and I'll
go how many lines can I take out of this
scene to make it actually like shorter
more concise without actually noticing
that anything's missing and you'd be
amazed how much you can pull out of a
scene without anybody noticing and then
that's how your movie starts pacing up
so what's a day in the life like in
between movies for you like when trying
to get another movie going it really it
really depends like it really really
depends on like you know do I have
something planned in it like another
movie going or do you know do I have you
know a script that I really want to work
on or am I you know finishing up post
the thing is like while finishing up
post usually I'm setting up meetings and
having you know people come see little
clips of the movie while I'm doing it so
that like I set up my next gig from
there but it really depends it really
depends on what you're doing but it's
you know people will buy into the
potential of things a lot so you know if
you can show them oh look how cool like
the making of this movie is look how
cool like the movie looks from like
these shots and blah blah blah it's easy
to move that into more work before
they're able to just judge like did I
like you know this performance or this
story if they're looking at just moments
it's you know because when people are
film is you know a very subjective thing
you could have somebody two people can
watch your movie one can love it and one
can hate it
so if you're just selling them on the
moments and the and and and what you
were able to bring to it and all that
stuff it's it's easier to set up more I
think because when they judge the movie
as a whole they're specifically going
like well did I like it or did I not
like it and sometimes you know let's say
you made a horror movie and you're inch
you're interviewing for you know I don't
know a comedy does that mean that what
if this person doesn't like horror
movies you know so are they gonna watch
it and go I'll you know I don't really
like this you know so you have to you
have to figure out you know away so I
think setting up meetings showing off
your footage and in certain ways is a
good a good idea for sure
do you tend to go back to the 10
companies for money ah it depends it
depends yeah yeah but I mean honestly
lately I've just gotten into the habit
of like just producing wise I've just
been being hired on to friends movies
like that's mostly what I've been doing
a lot of is because you know I have
friends that have like a slate that
they're doing and they just want me to
do like a bunch of movies with them so I
end up like you know producing cuz they
trust that I'll get it done and you know
so that's a lot of what I've done in the
past like two years that and then like
I'll direct like one or two movies each
year then you don't write or I write
them nd you as a director ask for cut
depends on depends on the movie it
depends on you know what I'm bringing to
the table
you know if I'm producing and directing
if I'm just directing if you know what
what my negotiated fee was depending on
like the budget of the movie you know
like if I'm taking lower money I'm gonna
walk back end if I'm taking you know
higher money that's negotiable do not
have back end it really just depends on
you know the movie also it depends on if
the movies pre-sold because if the
movies completely pre-sold you know
across the board and it's pre-sold in
every territory you might be negotiating
for you know back-end of nothing because
it's been pre-sold you know so it's it's
a a it really depends on the
circumstances it goes with trends but
also it goes against trends because you
have something like a get out that like
is is not like remote most stuff I think
you know one thing we're probably gonna
see is like politically geared horror I
think that's gonna be a big thing moving
forward like different you know focused
on different aspects of life with a
message in it and and putting you know
ordinary people
extra extraordinary circumstances so I
think that's you know you're gonna
experience a lot of that because you
know it's it's taking what people know
and expect and turning on its head and I
think you're gonna see a lot more of
stuff that's ripped from the headlines
because like you know the scariest stuff
is stuff that people can like relate to
themselves and relate to what's going on
in the world so you know when I worked
with Wes Craven Wes I literally said
like he got the idea from from Nightmare
on Elm Street from just reading
headlines and like there was a you know
people that had died in their dreams and
so that's what made him you know think
of that so I think you're gonna have you
know stuff that comes from headlines for
sure you know and and we live in a crazy
world so I think there's there's a lot
to pull from but I think we'll have a
lot more politically charged tour for
sure that's why I get out and stuff like
that worked how often do you take a risk
on no name actors and when you do why
what makes you want to take that risk
it really depends on the movie and it
depends on the role it depends on what
roles are left after having to fulfill
like the distributors requirements of
like names you know I did a movie that
we just did that was a non-union it
wasn't sad and so like it was much
easier to take risks on no-name actors
because we weren't getting names so we
were able to cast like just who we felt
were the best actors and like they you
know gave self tapes and stuff and the
director picked off of that so I think
you know it just depends on the
circumstances of the movie I know that's
kind of might not be the answer that you
wanted to hear but it's it's it's you
know I mean there's something to be said
about like you know you want the best
person for the job who who can give the
best performance but I think that's you
know a much more of a luxury when you
are not pre selling the movie but also
if you aren't you still have to protect
the investment with you know actors that
have name value
and working on big onset I don't know
I'm sure all actors are different but
how often do you let the actors follow
their impulses and you know their
instincts versus the technicality and
like what you're pursuing I think you
should always let them do that because
the beautiful thing about making a movie
is you could do multiple takes so why
don't you try it their way and try it
your way and decide an editing room you
want you want your actors to feel free
and open so let them try what they want
to try and then say oh that's great you
know let's do it again but let's try it
a little bit more like this this time
we've got we got that one let's try like
this and like you know you could try
different things and you know even if
you're not going to do what the actor
wants ultimately in the Edit you at
least have the option and they know you
have the option and I think that's
that's what's important
I wanted you to provide that sort of
atmosphere for the actor to feel
comfortable and feel open and not feel
kind of attached you mean you discuss
with them in advance that it's you know
collaborative and you want to be able to
collaborate and work with them and you
know you discuss a lot about the
character in advance with them and and
you kind of start to see where they're
gearing and go from there but people
will want to try stuff in the moment and
try different things and you know you
shouldn't stifle people's creativity in
that way you want your actor to feel
freed and if you if you edit in your
head and you know the edit and you know
okay if they do something you like great
you'll use it and if they do something
you don't like and you know okay I could
edit this out you know don't make a big
deal out of it if you know you can just
cut around it